I know you've heard about the new hand-tossed pizza from Pizza Hut.
It is good to the last, garlic, buttery bite.
In case you need to save a little for later and reheating pizza is your thing as it should be,...
...make sure you check out the new instructions on their new box.
I will read them for you now.
Number one: preheat the oven to 350 degrees.
This is very important.
Number two: remove the pizza from the box 'cause otherwise at 350 degrees the box...
Number three: resist picking off the toppings if you can.
And I can't.
Number four: transfer the cheesy goodness to the baking sheet.
Number five: bake for 5 to 10 minutes.
Spend time reflecting on your life, like this.
Number six: remove from oven and are you seriously still reading this?
Let's eat.
That's fun.
Go for greatness people.